das Völkerrecht wieder Stärken des
Völkerrecht wieder aufrichten dafür
sorgen dass ein Land das ein anderes mit
einem Angriffskrieg überzieht und in dem
Moment in dem es auf dem Schlachtfeld
ins Hintertreffen gerät sagt wenn ihr
uns jetzt weiter bedroht dann dann
bekämpfen wir euch mit Atomwaffen dass
ein Land mit so einer Strategie nicht
durchkommt weil ich die Sorge habe dass
das unsere ganze Welt überall sehr viel
unsicherer machen wird es werden sehr
viele Leute entsprechende Lehren daraus
ziehen und das darf nicht geschehen
deswegen muss diese Angriffskrieg
scheitern und scheitern heißt es dürfen
keine territorialen Gewinne daraus
erwachsen
dass der der große Punkt der ganz viele
Menschen in diesem Land auch umtreibt
übrigens inklusive Mia sind die
Wirtschaftssanktionen und zwar auch ob
die überhaupt greifen alle und ob sie
genug überprüft werden wie ist denn da
zu ihre Meinung jetzt nehmen wir mal
nicht die Waffenlieferung sondern als
Thema die Wirtschaftssanktionen wirklich
greifen die alle und hat die Regierung
da wirklich einen guten Job gemacht ja
also ich bin da ziemlich sicher dass die
Wirtschaftssanktionen greifen sie
greifen alle sie greifen nicht alle
gleich gut ja es gibt also
umgehungstatbestände beispielsweise wenn
man sich die die Sanktionen auf Öl
Importe anguckt dann gelingt es Russland
über Importe nach Indien einen Teil
davon zu umgehen aber insgesamt greifen
diese Wirtschaftssanktionen sie haben
die Lebenswirklichkeit in Russland
bereits massiv verändert und ich kommt
auch bei den Menschen in Russland an
dass sie im Krieg sind das versucht ihre
Regierung ja in sie davon zu überzeugen
dass das gar nicht der Fall wäre auch
das ist glaube ich ein wichtiger Faktor
für die öffentliche Meinung für die
Diskussionen Russland geführt werden
aber sie schwächen vor allen Dingen auch
die russische Industrie insbesondere die
russische Rüstungsindustrie und deswegen
ist es sehr gut dass es diese Sanktionen
gibt wo man sie noch verschaffen kann
sollte man das tun sie wird noch weiter
verschärfen da wo das möglich ist oder
sinnvoll möglich ist sollte man das tun
ja
Standpunkt dazu zum
Wirtschaftssanktionen ja
ich würde gerne noch mal beginnen was
der Felgentreu dargelegt hat die die
globale Welt also die Welt war schon
unsicher vor der ukraine-krise und die
These mit der Ukraine Krise und wenn
Russland wie auch immer irgendeinen
territorialen Gewinn zieht wird das
ganze noch viel schlimmer diese These
teile ich nicht es ist auch nicht so was
eben mir gesagt worden ist alle
Diktatoren der Welt würden sich das zum
Beispiel nehmen ich brauche einen
Diktator kein Beispiel zu geben wir
Unrecht in der Welt verbreitet und wir
Menschen tötet das Wissen diese
Kriminellen alleine und das Bauen die
sich nicht vom Putin oder anderen
Diktatoren anzuschauen da gibt es in der
Geschichte Beispiele zu Hauff
wir müssen uns auf die auf die Ukraine
konzentrieren also es ist keine
Blaupause für andere Diktatoren
beispielsweise
jeder Konflikt ist anders also gibt es
irgendein Konflikt der eine Blaupause
für einen anderen Konflikt war schon die
Weltkriege haben sich unterschieden die
einzelnen Konflikte sie je nach Region
sind unterschiedlich also zu glauben da
gibt es jetzt eine ein Exportmodell wie
greife ich meinen Nachbarn an und wie
gewinne ich also das ist nur wirklich
herbeigeredet das ist jetzt etwas
flapsig formuliert das ist natürlich
ihnen zuzugestehen aber man könnte ja
schon sagen wenn dann Putin bemerkt okay
der besten reagiert eigentlich nicht
wirklich wie beispielsweise bei der
Annexion der Krim das kann man ja
eigentlich jetzt schon als Blaupause
sehen dass er sich gedacht hat dass man
weitermachen kann oder nicht nee das
kann man nicht so als Blaupause sehen
weil die Annexion der Krim hat der
Westen aus meiner Sicht gar nicht so
falsch reagiert sondern wir haben ja
Verhandlungen geführt wir haben auch bei
der Destabilisierung der Ostukraine
Verhandlung geführt ich fand Ergebnisse
im Minsk Format gut im Übrigen hat sich
die Ukraine in vielen Punkten nicht an
diese Verhandlungsergebnisse gehalten
das muss auch mal zur Wahrheit gesagt
werden sondern der Westen hat schon aus
seiner Sicht vernünftig reagiert
dass man gegen jemanden der plötzlich
alle Regeln bricht und mit Gewalt die
Welt zu verändern versucht als als
moralisch werteorientierte Gemeinschaft
erst mal ein Stück zurückziehen muss und
überlegen muss wie reagieren wir denn
das versteht sich schon selbst das sieht
man im ersten Moment nicht ganz gut aus
aber im zweiten Moment glaube ich haben
wir uns noch ganz gut gefangen einmal
mit den Waffenlieferungen dafür bin ich
wir müssen den heldenlieferungen wir
müssen den heldenhaften Kampf dieses
ukrainischen Volkes unterstützen völlig
klar ich bin auch für Sanktionen weil
das ist im Grunde genommen nur noch das
einzige Mittel was wir neben den
Waffenlieferungen haben denn alles
andere ist ja schon längst gescheitert
nicht durch den Russland Konflikt
sondern die Entwicklung wer nimmt den VN
Sicherheitsrat noch ernst schon vor dem
Konflikt niemand wer nimmt die VN
Vollversammlung noch ernst schon vor dem
Konflikt niemand wer nimmt
internationale Gerichtshilfe noch ernst
schon vor dem Konflikt niemand das heißt
also wir haben unsere
konfliktmechanismen schon längst
verloren dass es übrigens ein Thema wo
wir immer dringend ran müssen wenn wir
das hier mal gelöst haben und da bleiben
uns nur Waffenlieferungen und es bleiben
uns nur Sanktionen über einzelne
sinnvolle Sanktionen muss man nochmal
diskutieren und ich fand die das
Beispiel von ronsheimer ganz gut dass
man die Hochtechnologie der Russen
abschneidet und sie damit in ihre
Rüstungsindustrie empfindlich getroffen
werden dass es nun ganz gelungener Kuh
des Westens so aber
dass alle die und ich komme noch mal auf
die These zurück dass alle die die hier
Hurra schreien und sagen also die Russen
dürfen nicht gewinnen dass alle die die
sagen wir dürfen uns nicht erpressen
lassen dass alle die die sagen also
jetzt müssen wir aber mal und so weiter
dass mir da einfach der Plan fehlt mit
mir fehlt die Lösung ich bin dafür dass
wir den Russen zeigen was eine Harke ist
ich bin dafür dass wir nicht dulden was
ein Angriffskrieg ist aber mir fehlt der
Plan wie soll das am Ende aussehen wenn
wir Sanktionen machen wenn wir Waffen
liefern und uns dann zurücksetzen und
sagen das wird ja wohl irgendwie alles
gut gehen das geht nicht das ist nicht
unsere Verantwortung wir müssen eine
aktive Friedenspolitik betreiben und
dazu gehört dass wir erstens erster
Schritt Waffenstillstand zweiter Schritt
Verhandlung wie kommen wir mit den
Russen klein und all ihrer Argumente die
wollen wir uns nach einer kurz
Unterbrechung anderen jetzt noch einmal
zurück zu meinem Kollegen pauronsheimer
der nach der Unterbrechung nämlich
leider nicht mehr bei uns sein kann
paula ist noch etwas abschließendes für
die Runde mitzuteilen
ich glaube dass man mehr an die Ukraine
glauben sollte und dass viele geglaubt
haben dass die Ukraine Kia verlieren
würde dass sie den Donbass schnell
verlieren würden die Wahrheit ist
momentan gewinnt die Ukraine ich glaube
das sollten sich alle die verinnerlichen
die immer glauben dass Russland
militärisch nicht zu schlagen ist
Russland wird momentan militärisch im
Osten und Süden geschlagen
eine letzte Frage habe ich doch noch
Paul mir ist eingefallen Wladimir
Klitschko hat ihr heute auch eine
Einladung an Bowlen ausgesprochen ist
dieser der denn schon gefolgt
ich habe mit Dieter Bohlen keinen
Kontakt von daher weiß ich das nicht er
hat sich noch nicht geäußert dazu ich
glaube dass tatsächlich was Wladimir
Klitschko und andere machen in der
Ukraine tatsächlich ein ein gutes
Beispiel dafür ist ja es ist jemand der
sagt schaut euch das selbst an und ich
glaube auch an einige in der Runde
schaut euch an was in Orten wie in
Butcher und anderen passiert ist es
etwas anderes ob man das im Fernsehen
sieht oder ob man wenn man dann als
Experte im TV ist oder Gastbeiträge
schreibt oder was auch immer tut sollte
man in der Ukraine gewesen sein